[Música]
llega ya nuestro espacio de revista de
prensa como siempre con Rosa Pérez más
deus Rosa bienvenida a este estudio
Gracias Rodrigo Bueno te estás
convirtiendo ya en nuestra periodista
especializada en documentos filtrados
porque hablamos de ello ya el lunes y
hoy volvemos con un artículo del moscow
Times que dice cinco cosas que los
documentos filtrados del pentágono
revelan sobre el ejército ruso cuéntanos
Rosa Pues sí las informaciones que
contienen estos documentos se van
conociendo un poco en cuentagotas y se
estima que se filtraron un centenar de
documentos lo que pasa es que no se
puede saber con exactitud porque como ya
dijimos el lunes estos documentos fueron
apareciendo en distintos portales de
internet y ahí han pasado a Telegram a
Twitter algunos Pues están
desapareciendo de los lugares donde
fueron publicados pero bueno como
decíamos gran parte de la información
filtrada hace referencia a la situación
de la guerra en Ucrania y de estos cinco
puntos que destaca el Moscú Time de
informaciones relativas al ejército ruso
el primero hace referencia al número de
muertes y de según estos documentos
desde el inicio de la guerra y a fecha
de un documento de principios de este
año 2023 43.000 soldados rusos han
muerto en combate y el ejército ruso
cuenta ya con más de 190.000 bajas no lo
que incluiría además de las muertes Pues
los heridos por parte del ejército
ucraniano serían más de 17.000 los
soldados ucranianos muertos y más de
125.000 Las bajas otro punto el segundo
dice Rusia conoce los reverses que ha
sufrido en la guerra lo que parece
bastante lógico no y según un documento
fechado del mes de febrero en ese
momento el Estado Mayor de la defensa de
Rusia informó que sus tropas en el este
de Ucrania tenían una capacidad de
combate limitada tercer punto Estados
Unidos interceptó planes específicos de
ataques rusos no contra centrales
eléctricas almacenes militares tropas
etcétera cuarto punto Estados Unidos
poseía un documento detallado de la
estrategia de Rusia para combatir los
tanques que los países de la otan iban a
mandar o van a mandar a Ucrania puntos
que se resumen en el quinto Y es que
Estados Unidos ha penetrado casi en
todos los cuerpos y estratos militares
de Rusia no Incluso el grupo Wagner
tienes quizás ya otro especial de
Navidad Rosa adelantandonos mucho tiempo
a todo lo que venga final de año vamos
con el gif porque la periodista alisa
orlova titula documentos filtrados
revelan las dudas de Estados Unidos
sobre la contraofensiva ucraniana Sí
exactamente Rodrigo y es que algunas de
las otras informaciones que han
destacado los medios de comunicación
respecto a esta filtración por ejemplo
de Guardián hacía referencia a que en un
punto determinado de la guerra 97
agentes de las fuerzas especiales de la
otan han estado presentes sobre el
terreno en Ucrania de los cuales 50 eran
de Reino Unido afp destaca que Estados
Unidos duda de la capacidad de Ucrania
de continuar defendiéndose con los
sistemas de defensa antiaérea que pronto
dice se le van a acabar a este ritmo y
el Washington post dice que Estados
Unidos duda de la capacidad de éxito de
la contraofensiva ucraniana de primavera
lo que rescata este medio como tú decías
no el post este medio ucraniano que
empieza este artículo diciendo los
documentos filtrados que no han sido
verificados en esto insiste mucho este
artículo resaltan los desafíos que
enfrentan las fuerzas ucranianas en
términos de equipamiento entrenamiento y
coordinación dificultades que podrían
obstaculizar su capacidad para
contrarrestar de manera efectiva al
ejército ruso no como decíamos este
artículo insiste mucho en que los
documentos no están verificados algunos
dicen que puede ser una estrategia Rusia
para socavar la moral de Ucrania
Mientras que el artículo sin embargo
respalda la versión de que esta sería
una arma híbrida occidental contra Rusia
quizás estamos viendo algunas fisuras en
ese apoyo a Ucrania o realmente dudas de
lo que pueda pasar ahora en primavera Sí
realmente dudas también a lógicas a no
Rodrigo porque pues esto no que hemos
comentado muchas veces occidente está
una gran cantidad de ayuda en términos
económicos y militares y también pues Es
lógico que tenga sus dudas sobre cómo se
va a usar claro Rosa Bueno vamos a
cambiar de tema vamos con un artículo
del New York Times del periodista Roger
cohen me has estado Ya hablando de este
artículo bastante interesante que dice
así de la alfombra roja a la perrera
macron regresa de China a la
consternación de sus aliados que nos
cuentan y rosa pues quiero empezar
leyendo las primeras líneas de este
artículo que dice lo siguiente el
presidente Manuel macron aterrizó en
China directamente sobre una alfombra
roja con toda la pompa de una visita de
estado un tour de tres días una fiesta
del amor con la que claramente esperaba
ganar un lugar para Francia en la mesa
de las grandes potencias del mundo un
mundo cambiado por la invasión rusa de
Ucrania y el surgimiento de Beijing como
árbitro global bien este artículo
formado por Roger cohen dice que sin
embargo la recepción de macron a su
vuelta a Europa Fue bastante fría que
macron después de Esther de Esta visita
a China está más aislado que nunca que
es impopular en Francia por la reforma
de las pensiones y es desconfiado en el
exterior no dice su posición en la
visita a China preocupó aliados desde
Varsovia hasta Washington adoptó el
lenguaje de Beijing de la necesidad de
un mundo multipolar liberado de bloques
y de la mentalidad de la Guerra Fría
además en una entrevista en político
dijo que Europa no debe seguir
ciegamente la doctrina estadounidense
respecto a China y Taiwán y escribe el
periodista Roger cohen hablar de
autonomía estratégica no este concepto
en Boca de macron siempre que habla de
política exterior dice parece una
provocación en un momento en que Estados
Unidos está mandando un apoyo militar
masivo a Ucrania no está autonomía
estratégica de Europa Pues que debe
reconocer el papel al menos financiero
de Estados Unidos en la defensa de
Ucrania dice además se sumó una cuestión
de timing que ha aumentado la polémica
dice macron habló horas antes de que
china empezara los ejercicios de
intimidación sobre contra Taiwán no
macron dijo que él estaba agradecido de
hecho a China de que esperara que él que
macron saliera del espacio aéreo chino
para digamos lanzar estos ejercicios de
intimidación contra Taiwán bueno todo es
cuestión de perspectivas no Rodrigo y
respecto al discurso de ayer de macron
en la haya el periodista no le da mucho
caso como tampoco le ha hecho mucho caso
la prensa francesa simplemente destaca
nuestra Europa está hecha de sueños no
quiero que mis sueños sean soñados en el
idioma de otros esta frase que pronunció
macron pero que dice el periodista no
está claro si se refería a los chinos o
a los estadounidenses bien y acaba
señalando que mañana hay otra
movilización que está poniendo sobre las
cuerdas a macron contra la reforma de
las pensiones
le tendríamos que preguntar a Úrsula
fonder Legend que piensa también de ella
y de lo que dijo en China porque parece
que se contradijeron totalmente no
posiciones muy opuestas a respecto al
papel que debe seguir a Europa a Europa
digamos respecto a Estados Unidos bueno
Rosa pues muchas gracias por esta
revista de prensa nos vemos mañana
quizás con más filtraciones nos vemos
mañana Rodrigo Muchas gracias Rosa